just recently the European Southern
Observatory put out a press release
about a rather beautiful image of a
galaxy here it is there's nothing
particularly special about this galaxy
you know there are many tens of
thousands of galaxies of this sort of
size out there in the sky but the reason
why they're sort of excited about this
one
is because they've been studying this
image of it and they come to the
conclusion it's pretty much a twin of
our own galaxy the Milky Way
one of the problems in studying our own
galaxy is it's very hard to kind of get
a perspective as to what it actually
looks like because we're stuck in the
middle of it and so you can sort of
can't see the wood for the trees you
really can't tell exactly what's going
on on the large scale and so although in
some ways we have by far the best data
on the Milky Way than on any other
galaxy in other ways we don't actually
have an overall very good perspective on
it and so the nice thing about this
galaxy is it gives us a kind of a twin
that we can use to say well you know
when we want to think about what the
large-scale structure of our own galaxy
might look like it probably looks
something very much like this so this
galaxy has the rather uninspiring name
of NGC 6744 so cool because it's in the
new general catalog which of course
isn't very new now the table is whenever
you create a new catalog you called it
the new catalog and this one was at the
end of the 19th centuries not a
particularly new catalog at this point
but especially a catalog of galaxies and
other nebulae and so it's about seven or
eight thousand objects in there so it's
one of the with just one of the 8,000
odd galaxies in that particular catalog
they've released that picture they think
it's bit of a twin what do you think is
it a good twin it's pretty good so I
have a kind of a hobby interest of
actually producing three-dimensional
images of astronomical objects and in
fact the first one I did a number of
years ago was actually to make a model
of the Milky Way and the reason why I do
that is because I actually produce these
things so this is these are these little
three-dimensional sculptures of
astronomical objects I produce as kind
of just a little hobby thing that I do
the first one I did was of the Milky Way
as I said it's very hard to actually
make a detailed map of the Milky Way
so what I did was I took all the
cutting-edge astronomical data that the
was about eight or nine years ago and
sort of combined it all together to make
the best possible picture I could of
what I thought the galaxies would look
like from the outside and the bottom
line is that this actually ends up
looking very much like this galaxy NGC
6744 that's the same bar-like structure
in the middle even the pattern of the
spiral arms is very much the same in
this model of the Milky Way as it is in
this galaxy NGC 6744
so the what this the way these things
are made is they're they're laser-cut so
there are actually a few hundred
thousand tiny little fractures in the
glass here does each dot represent us
there's only a few hundred thousand dots
in here and so of course in order for it
to really represent the the Milky Way
you'd have to be up in the billions of
dots but the the density of dots
reflects the density of stars so that
the where there are more dots it's in
proportion to the number of stars that
would actually be in that part of the
Milky Way when that new picture came out
recently did you pull out one of your
models and do bit of a compare
I absolutely did yeah and actually it
turns out that the this galaxy rotates
in the opposite direction from the Milky
Way which just means you need to look at
the Milky Way from the back instead of
the front if you want the spiral arms to
go around the same way but if you do
that it really matches up remarkably
well this was actually the the map I
made of the Milky Way when I was putting
all these data together and so this is
kind of a face on view and edge-on view
of the Milky Way using the best possible
data to try and figure out what the
structure of the galaxy was how big the
bar in the middle was this rectangular
kind of structure in the middle where
the spiral arms are and so on and the
remarkable thing is if you do compare
this to this image of NGC 6744
they do end up looking remarkably
similar kinds of galaxies another kind
of similarity with the Milky Way is that
this galaxy has a lot of galaxies do has
a companion here is it's a little faint
to see on this particular image but the
size and brightness of this companion
galaxy and even its distance away from
the the main galaxy is very comparable
to the Large Magellanic Cloud in the
Milky Way so again it's another kind of
connection it's probably not that
unusual so most galaxies have companions
but it's kind of interesting that it
comes out with a companion that's so
similar to that on the Milky Way perhaps
the most famous galaxies that we see
photos of is Andromeda why is end
ramallah not a twin of the Milky Way I
always think I always imagined that's
what the Milky Way looks like and draw
the problem with Andromeda is because of
the way it's oriented it's fairly close
to edge on the way we see it and so
actually it's quite hard to tell exactly
what it does look like what its spiral
structure looks like what it said
whether it has a central bar is still
even for example a matter of some
argument so it could be that the
Andromeda galaxy is also very similar to
the Milky Way but just because of the
way it's oriented it's because it's not
faced on we just can't see those kind of
characteristics so we can't really make
that sort of judgment we happen to live
in the Milky Way is there still any
doubt about the structure of the Milky
Way amongst astronomers
oh very much so so just for example a
couple of years ago somebody published a
paper saying that that rectangular thing
in the middle of the bar might actually
be twice as long as people have talked
it was so it really is very tough to
kind of disentangle what's going on
within our own galaxy just because of
our location within it and so actually
it really you know even now are there's
a lot of kind of discussion as to
exactly what the structure the Milky Way
might be